Good acting often requires years of training,
a ton of effort, and a little luck. Sometimes,
though, no amount of any of those things can help
otherwise talented actors affect an accent that's
simply beyond their abilities. These are the
on-screen accents that were absolutely horrendous.
Just because you once starred in
an Austin Powers movie doesn't
mean you can actually pull off a decent
British accent. Just ask Heather Graham.
Perhaps the worst part of Graham's atrocious
accent in the 2001 Ripper flick From Hell
is that she just can't seem to
decide which one to go with.
The United Kingdom is home to
dozens of different accents and
dialects — unfortunately, it seems that
Graham is unable to pull off any of them.
"Well, you'd better throw us in jail, then, 'cos
we've no money for food and no money for a doss."
During this movie, Graham jumps from
cockney to a kind of Irish to something
altogether unintelligible, proving that the
actress may just have benefited from some
more thorough accent coaching. In fact,
sometimes it seems like she's barely even
trying at all — and simply sounds more like
a Hollywood actress than a Whitechapel local.
"I wish I could show you the little village
where I was born. It's so lovely there."
Not even a spoonful of sugar can make Dick van
Dyke's attempt at Cockney English more palatable.
In fact, he himself once called his work
in the 1964 classic Mary Poppins, quote,
"the most atrocious cockney
accent in the history of cinema."
"What did I tell ya? There's
a whole world at your feet."
At the time, however, van Dyke didn't
know how far off he really was.
As the actor later told The Guardian:
"Someone should have told me I
needed to work on my Cockney accent.
Nearly everyone in the Mary Poppins cast was a
Brit, but no one said anything. [...] Years later
I asked Julie [Andrews]: 'Why didn't you tell me?'
She said it was because I was working so hard."
Still, van Dyke continues to keep a
positive attitude about the whole thing,
despite actual Brits apparently never
letting him forget it. He explained:
"People in the U.K. love
to rib me about my accent.
I will never live it down. They ask what
part of England I was meant to be from,
and I say it was a little shire in the north
where most of the people were from Ohio."
"Now, I always say there's
nothing like a good joke."
What happens when a French-American
actor plays an immortal Scottish
swordsman? Well, something like this:
"This cannot be. It's the Devil's work."
Christopher Lambert's fake Scottish
accent in 1986's Highlander is
undoubtedly one of the worst
to ever hit the big screen.
Most of the time, Lambert barely sounds
Scottish at all, and the movie isn't helped
by the fact that actual Scottish actor
Sean Connery plays an Egyptian/Spaniard
who sounds neither Egyptian nor Spanish. He
does, however, sound a lot like Sean Connery.
"I am Juan Sánchez Villalobos Ramírez,
Chief metallurgist to King Charles V
of Spain. And I'm at your service."
But hey, who needs accents when
you have the Macleod Longsword?
Having cemented his reputation as a major
blockbuster movie star, in the early '90s
Tom Cruise decided to prove that he could
really act. So, not long after earning an
Oscar nomination for Born on the Fourth
of July, he signed up for Far and Away.
Co-written and directed by Ron Howard and
co-starring Cruise's wife Nicole Kidman,
Far and Away tells the epic story of a young Irish
immigrant couple who arrive in the United States
in the late 19th century, searching for a
better life. But in his efforts to play a
representative of the 1800s Irish diaspora, he
missed one major element: a decent Irish accent.
"I'm not going to a distant world. I'm of
Ireland, and I'll stay in Ireland 'til I die."
In 2021, Irish Central called Cruise's voice
work, quote, "truly appalling" and added that:
"[It] sounds like how a Hollywood film
executive imagines Irish people talk."
Leonardo DiCaprio is one of the
best actors of his generation — and
in 2007 he earned his third Academy
Award nomination for Blood Diamond.
An exposé of the inhumane, brutal,
and deadly diamond trade in Africa,
the film takes place during the Sierra Leone Civil
War in the 1990s. DiCaprio plays Danny Archer,
a diamond smuggler turned activist who hails
from Zimbabwe, but spent years in South Africa.
Both of those countries were colonized and long
occupied by European nations; namely the U.K.
and the Netherlands. But DiCaprio's accent in
the movie doesn't sound much like a typical
South African accent, nor does it seem
English or Dutch-based either. Instead,
DiCaprio's character sounds more like he might
be from another part of the world entirely.
"You Americans, you Americans love
to talk about your feelings, huh?
What does that mean, what does that mean?"
Trevor Noah, a native of South Africa,
even called out DiCaprio's voice performance
on a 2019 episode of The Daily Show:
"We've gotta get back to
those bloody get the diamonds,
get the bloody diamonds. What are you,
a drunk Australian? What are you doing?"
Martin Scorsese's crime thriller The Departed is
an epic tale with a hefty and confident state of
place — that place being Boston. Scorsese loaded
the cast with actors well-known for their Beantown
roots, including Mark Wahlberg and Matt Damon, but
he also brought in the legendary Jack Nicholson,
who portrays Irish-American
gang boss Frank Costello.
Maybe Scorsese thought that Wahlberg and
Damon's natural accents were enough for this
very Bostonian movie, or that their speech
patterns would simply rub off on Nicholson.
Or maybe he just thought that Nicholson
would do his job as one of the most
acclaimed actors of all time and give
that Massachusetts brogue a try. Alas…
“Heavy lies the crown… sorta thing.”
To be fair, sometimes Nicholson
does provide a serviceable accent,
dropping an "r" here and there like a true
native Boston man. But then, on occasion,
he'll give a line reading in a genuinely
comical, hugely over-the-top Irish accent.
"Oh, I love the dear silver
that shines in your hair."
Justin Timberlake is an entertainer at
heart. His career began in childhood,
when he was a member of the always singing,
dancing, and smiling Mickey Mouse Club — and
later found mega-fame as a member of the boy
band *NSYNC. Timberlake brought that same kind
of intense energy to some of his early film
acting roles, particularly that of arrogant
French Canadian hockey player Jacques Grandé
in the Mike Myers' 2008 comedy The Love Guru.
Timberlake goes as big, broad, and wacky
as he possibly could have in the film,
so naturally he opts for a
truly cartoonish French accent,
reminiscent more of Pepe Le Pew
than an actual French-speaker.
"Stay away from my girlfriend! Wooooo!"
The real problem here, however, is
that Jacques isn't French — he's
French Canadian, which is supposed to
be a distinctive dialect in of itself.
Robin Hood is a distinctively English folk hero.
A rogue ex-aristocrat in the English system,
he steals from the rich and gives to the
poor, operating with his band of Merry
Men out of a home base in Sherwood
Forest, near the city of Nottingham.
The tale of Robin Hood has been put to film many
times, including a take in 2010 that cost nearly
$200 million. Producers likely wanted to make
sure they got a good return on their investment
and preferred a bankable star in the title
role — someone like Russell Crowe, for example.
Perhaps it just didn't matter, then, that Crowe
does not, will not, and seemingly cannot speak
with an East Midlands accent, the regional
English dialect used around Nottingham.
"Every Englishman's home is his castle. What
we would ask, your majesty, is liberty."
Upon Robin Hood's release, critics quickly
called out Crowe's accent; the actor even
abruptly left an interview with a BBC Radio host
who said he sounded more Irish than English.
Eight years later, actor Con O'Neill brought
up Crowe's Robin Hood accent on Twitter.
Crowe replied that his accent
was supposed to be that of:
"A child born in Barnsley, on his father’s death,
taken to France at age 6, travels across Europe
to the Middle East on foot, fights in the
third crusade for Richard I, alongside men
from all parts of Britain, Ireland and France &
finally returns to England a man in his 40’s."
In the 1997 action movie Con Air, Nicolas Cage
plays a recently paroled convict and former U.S.
Army Ranger who gets stuck on a prisoner transport
plane after it's hijacked by the other prisoners.
His character, Cameron Poe, is said to be
from Alabama, so Cage affects a slow, languid
drawl — and seems to be aiming for something
close to Forrest Gump by way of Foghorn Leghorn.
“Nice jet. You can take Cindino and
leave the rest to rot, for all I care.
You fire that weapon, 20 pissed
off prisoners are gonna hear it."
This is an especially strange choice for
Cage, a notoriously quirky man who speaks
with a twinge of the South in real life — even
though he was born in Burbank, California.
Sam Worthington starred in the
highest-grossing film ever released,
and yet he probably could still walk down
the street unaccosted — because the scenes
in Avatar in which his face was actually
on screen were kept to a bare minimum.
The Australian actor's time as Jake Sully in the
movie is mostly spent as a combination of CGI
and voice acting, as his character
inhabits a lab-grown avatar meant
to look like the inhabitant of an alien planet.
Unfortunately, this means that the audience
is basically forced to focus on Jake's voice.
Naturally, then, many have noticed that
Worthington's attempt at sounding like
a tough American Marine veteran
actually sounds like anything but.
"I needed their help,
and they needed mine. But to ever face them again,
I was gonna have to take it to a whole new level."
His prominent Australian accent
leaks through often during the movie,
despite undergoing extensive work with a dialect
coach before filming began. But maybe there's
only so much you can work with — after all,
as director James Cameron told Total Film:
"His accent was thicker than Crocodile Dundee."
In a crowded cast of terrific
actors at the top of their game,
Don Cheadle somehow managed to pull off one
of the most memorable performances in the 2001
remake of Ocean's Eleven. He played Basher Tarr,
the member of Danny Ocean's heist crew who is an
expert in explosives — and who is supposed to
come from a British, working-class background.
Cheadle was born in the American Midwest, however,
so he worked hard with an on-set speech coach in
order to perfect his character's Cockney accent.
Although, "perfect" might not be the right word.
"Alright chaps — hang onto your knickers."
Once the movie was released, however, it
appears that Cheadle's accent provoked a
few strong reactions. The actor later
said that, on a visit to London:
"Someone would come up and say
'love that character, mate,
it's great.' And the next street
someone would come up and say,
'don't ever do that again!' Someone did a u-turn
to come drive by me and cuss me out for the part."
Cheadle is so over the criticism of his accent,
in fact, that he has even taken to supporting a
fan theory that explains why it sounds so off:
that Basher is really an American
pretending to be a Cockney Brit.
"Oh, leave it out."
Oliver Stone's Natural Born Killers is an
eye-popping, style-hopping extravaganza.
The movie follows spree killers Mickey
and Mallory Knox, whose criminal fame
is spurred on by Wayne Gale, the host of
a trashy TV show called American Maniacs.
Robert Downey Jr. is both loathsome and bombastic
as the exploitative and ratings-hungry Gale,
whom Stone later explained is based
on a combination of Geraldo Rivera
and Australian tabloid journalist Steve
Dunleavy. It's actually the latter's Australian
accent that Downey is trying to imitate
here, but he doesn't quite get it right.
"Do you think those nitwits out there
in zombieland remember anything?"
Instead, Downey's accent is some bizarre
combination of South African, a couple of
different British dialects, some New Zealand vocal
features, and perhaps just a hint of Australian.
In 2005, Oscar-winning filmmaker Cameron
Crowe received the worst reviews of his career
with his rom-com flick Elizabethtown.
Starring English actor Orlando Bloom,
it appears that Elizabethtown doesn't really
know what kind of movie it wants to be;
it's a romantic comedy, but it's also
about a guy mourning his father's death,
as well as a professional redemption story, and
a movie about a man returning to his hometown.
Similarly, Bloom is all over
the place with his accent,
despite some extensive accent
training. At the time, the actor said:
"It wasn't easy to master an American accent. I
had a lot of help from a dialect
coach. But I did all right. No?"
"A billion dollars! That's a lot of million."
Bloom's character is supposed to be a Kentucky
native, but the actor is never able to really
commit to a specific Southern accent. The way he
delivers the script's dialogue in a wishy-washy,
non-specific American way is a little
reminiscent of that of his co-star,
Alec Baldwin… but, for some reason,
it also sounds kinda Scottish, too.
"How's that going?"
"Sort of a wait and see."
"Oh yeah?"
"But then I waited and I saw."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.